hey guys so it's been a little while
since the last video and I'd like to
pull adjust that it's not cuz I've
forgotten you guys
in fact that's actually because I've
been so busy working on the Pioneer in
this channel that I haven't had a chat
stuff made a video there's a lot of
exciting stuff coming to the bio near
both YouTube channel and the blog I'm
excited to show you guys it so please
just bear with me for a little while
what there's not quite as much going on
on the channel it's gonna be worth it
hopefully so it's gonna be a quick one
but hopefully I'll upload something a
bit meteor next week today I just want
to speak to you quickly so that we've
got something in the bag and I'm going
to talk about embodied cognition because
I find that a fascinating subject and
something that's quite misunderstood
among a lot of people on YouTube so
embodied cognition what is it well I'll
tell you what it's not it's not thinking
with your body as cool as that may be
it's not that your brain is distributed
all throughout your body
you know like Tony Stark can that really
rubbish ultimates comic which you've
probably never read and that's a random
reference and I shouldn't have even
brought up what it is about it's about
the way that you do think not with your
body so much as thanks to your body and
in a way with your body but not using
your body so that's it yeah so now you
understand what embody cognition is
dinner when you think normally you
probably experience yourself thinking
with words and inner monologue or at
least that's what it feels like they're
actually many different ways to think
you can think visually you can think
with uncivilized thought but that's not
on topic normally you think of thought
as being like an inner monologue like
the little thought boxes you get in
comics this of course is English and
your brain doesn't naturally understand
English if you see what I mean so the
question is how are you translating
English thought from from your own
thoughts and also from what people are
saying to you how do you translate that
into something your brain understands
how is it being interpreted it into pure
reason what is the kind of base level
machine code of the brain when you
program on a computer you program in a
programming language like C++ C sharp
Java and then that gets converted into
machine code which isn't really legible
for most humans and then that gets
converted into binary code
and that represents on and off switches
so one is on and a zero is off but the
point is that the computer doesn't
understand C++ or C sharp which is
statements like if then and else that
sounds like English likewise the
assumption is the brain doesn't
understand English the brain has some
kind of machine codes somehow the brain
has pure reason and pure understanding
and this is what our thoughts based on
this is what the words we hear and we
think are translated into in order for
us to understand them and take action on
them then why is this machine code
that's what psychologists ask and they
used to call it mental Eve's mentally
wasn't an actual theory it was just a
word given to something that they didn't
really understand so mentally the idea
was you hear words you think words to
translate them into mental ease and
that's pure reason but now starting to
think that mental ease is actually not
very useful idea instead the brain
doesn't work on a language at all
there's no base code for the brain
instead the brain actually uses your
body to understand so everything that
you think and everything you learn is
related back to your physical experience
this is just the theory but it's one
that I think makes a lot of sense so you
say I'm talking to you and I say I was
walking through the woods and then all
of a sudden the massive bear came also
it was cold
what's going on in your brain is that
you're interpreting what I'm saying as I
said to you and the way you're doing
that is by sort of experiencing it
you're visualizing it your visual on
yourself walking through the woods I
mean walking through the woods you've
maybe remember what it's like to feel
cold you remember what it's like to feel
scared and if we look at what happens in
the brain during these times actually
the brain areas light up as though
you're experiencing the things I'm
talking about so your brain simulates
what's happening likewise if you plan
something if you think I'm going to go
and open the door later it's a great
plans and sort of exciting evenings I
have well then what actually happens at
you you visualize but you also feel
yourself going up to the door handle and
seeing it in your hand you might
actually so even get a sensation what a
twisting feels like so your brain again
is replaying it using your body to kind
of visualize what's happening and so in
doing that you understand it and then
you've got layers of abstraction so we
need you Matt or when you talk in
metaphor you have to convert it back and
back but ultimately it's still based on
physical experience so in short we rely
on our physical experiences in order to
understand everything and without having
evolved and grown up in a physical
environment we might not have the tools
that we need to be able to engage in
thought this has all sorts of
implications that has implications for
artificial intelligence for instance
because they might be barking up the
wrong tree trying to make an AI that is
entirely software based it might be that
it needs to have a physical presence a
body of some kind in order to have any
kind of understanding in order to really
truly understand words and give them
meaning and apply them in a useful
context and then to be able to engage in
abstract thought by building on that it
also means in theory that using our
bodies and increasing our awareness
could well improve our ability to think
and also has an interesting implications
for CBT cognitive behavioral therapy
which as you know if you've read my blog
and watch by the video I think you can
use to enhance performance by convincing
yourself to have certain physiological
responses and the times that they're
most appropriate so the reason I think
that CBT and thoughts can be used to
trigger certain emotional responses or
to making yourself more focused or more
alert or to improve your memory is
because essentially you're not just
thinking it you're experiencing it and
when you visualize something happening
your body responds almost as though it
is happening so if you think you're
gonna fail you learn it in your head but
you also almost experience failing you
must produce these hormones and these
neurotransmitters and you're pretty much
balanced to fail anyways this is an
interesting subjects I think and the
main reason I want to bring up is just
because you hear a lot of people saying
like you need to balance and use it for
prior exception because of embodied
cognition but actually no they have
nothing to do with each other it's just
a very interesting subject and one that
I thought you guys might find
interesting cuz I don't think there's
any videos that I found on YouTube about
it you'd like to learn more about it and
please check
my video on YouTube and of course as
usual in the coming weeks and they'll be
talking about body building and working
online and apps and brain training and
nootropics and all these things again as
usual I'm gonna be hopefully increasing
my output and yes there are big things
on the way like I teased earlier on so
if you like to learn more about that and
sign up to the mailing list and I hope
you'll stay with me stay tuned subscribe
like share and all those things thanks
very much for watching and bye for now